what are your thoughts on birth control
methods
particularly any possible long-term
effects of hormonal types
if you had girls how would you advise
them on the matter
god that's so many questions and there's
it's
so good and um you know just to start
with the final one
first you know part of
part of why feminism
when it has made sense has looked the
way it has in the past and why
modern feminism often doesn't look like
it makes sense
is actually based on the correct
recognition
uh that to be female and to be male is
different and uh
that effectively contraception
effective contraception with you know
one large exception
um you know the condom basically falls
falls to women and
this is you know is it fair no is it
true
yes and is there any way around it it
doesn't seem to be not yet
you know it would it would be great if
there was work on
um possible modes of contraception for
men
uh that didn't involve condoms and i'm
sure there's some but there's not nearly
as much
um but it's also physiologically harder
to get it to work which may be why there
is not
as much i think i i believe that that is
true
yes um for reasons that are interesting
which maybe we'll come back to us
yeah yeah maybe we will um so yeah
hormonal birth control
is um
is not perfect you know when when the
pill was first introduced it was at much
higher doses
than it has been for a long time um
i was certainly on you know very very
low dose pill for many
many many many years and at some point
decided that
uh basically i hadn't been an adult
without having exogenous hormones um
that were working as contraception and
that didn't strike me as a particularly
good idea much you know it is
it is certainly less worrisome to me
than allowing children and
and teenagers to take cross-sex hormones
which is currently all the rage among
some
medical professionals but it is also
there is no reason to think that it is
totally harmless
even at very low doses that said
um there is a way to mitigate the harm
the potential harm
of hormonal birth control for women that
is mostly not done but could basically
um not necessarily mitigate the harm but
provide a
adaptive advantage that was never
imagined when
the pill was first on the market that
could actually
help which is to say that in among
hunter-gatherers
uh most females girls and women
experience something less and i'm i'm
making up a number here and it's going
to vary across undergraduate societies
but something less than 15 menses
like you know bleeding events menstrual
cycles
in their entire lifetime in their entire
lifetime
and this is because it's not that they
are pregnant their entire lives
but that the combination of being
pregnant during which you have
uh amenorrhea you're not you're not
menstruating and then
when you are breastfeeding at least on
demand and
more and with greater than a frequency
of i don't remember what it is every
six or eight hours or something you have
what's called lactation elementaria you
don't
you don't menstruate due to the
effectively the competing hormones of
producing milk
in which you know the adaptive reason
being if your body is producing milk for
an extent baby
or toddler then it is not yet the time
to get pregnant again because you are
still working to
to feed a child um
the combination of you missed one yep
um so there's um
lactational amenorrhea there is
gestation uh gestational
and there is starvational although i
don't know if that's what
yeah but you know if you uh female
marathon runners for example are often
so lean that they don't menstruate so
basically the body has all of these
protections
against getting pregnant when uh having
the resources to raise a child
uh is not evident and so anyway
those you're saying in principle could
be
uh borrowed as a
well specifically it seems that so
rarely in human history until
post-industrial revolution
have women had so many periods
uh that uh there is decent reason to
think and not enough research yet
uh that having so many periods actually
can cause long-term health effects like
for instance anemia that that much loss
of blood over that you know that
that reliably uh can cause things like
iron deficiency
uh and so you know why not if you are
taking a very low dose
hormonal contraception uh take it not 21
out of 28 days
but um 28 out of 28 days and
and don't maintain uh demonstration so
you know originally the
the dude who invented it imagined that
menstruation was an absolutely necessary
thing
um you know and there are all sorts of
you know weird ideas around
cleanliness and dirtiness and and
women's reproductive
health not being um something that
uh was being considered as carefully as
it might have been as it probably would
be now
um but if you know if if the pill
instead allowed for say you know one
menstrual cycle in a year as opposed to
13 of them
uh that would have only a
slightly greater effect with regard to
the exogenous hormones
but it might actually have a um a
positive effect on the other direction
of not having the women who are on them
uh
have whatever negative health effects
there are from having so many menses
and it would almost certainly preserve
fertility
uh for longer this is probably true
so anyway we can argue about the various
costs and benefits of that but
um but anyway that's probably the case
yeah but yeah i mean very very low level
um hormonal birth control
is not perfect there's nothing there's
nothing that is
oh no lesbianism works like a charm hmm
yeah okay
all right just thought i'd mention it it
is very effective
um so i've heard yes yep uh
yeah um i mean there's
yeah you know there's there's stuff that
is
um that some people really don't
abide things like the copper iud which
is apparently extremely painful for some
people and the hormonal iud is not
recommended if you
are not past your desire to have any
any more or any children um diaphragms
are
messy but effective it's it's
there's not a perfect solution and the
hormonal ones are
by far the most satin forget
and easiest but there are potential
long-term effects
yep all right so just a word on why it
is harder to generate
male birth control yeah if you think
about it
males because they have two reproductive
strategies one of them does not involve
investment males are basically built
uh with a strong bias in favor of
fertilizing females irrespective
of the wisdom of that
because basically if a man is not
intending to stick around
then though the offspring he may produce
is very
costly the cost doesn't fall to him and
therefore might as well sort of like
seeds falling from a tree might as well
germinate even if they land in
bad soil because the alternative is
no no functional offspring so
anyway the idea is female bodies are
much more reluctant
to produce offspring because the cost is
so damn high that
they only want to produce offspring when
conditions are hospitable
and therefore it is easier to interrupt
that system because that system is
looking out for all sorts of conditions
that say it's not a good time to
reproduce
yeah so anyway that bias is
not inflicted by the patriarchy the
patriarchy may find it convenient
but um nonetheless i mean that's that's
actually the thing that a lot of a lot
of what gets uh
put on the patriarchy's bill the
patriarchy may have
been using opportunistically but wasn't
actually its invention that's right
mostly
we in the patriarchy were just very very
lucky we did not
set this up we would not have thought of
it we would not have
had the dedication to make it work we
just lucked into it
and we're sorry are you though
yeah sometimes a little bit a little bit